I can't imagine living in a world without
being able to drink milk with my cookies.
But fortunately today, we have the ability to
digest lactose products even if you're lactose intolerant.
>> Some companies actually sell a product which is lactase in pill
form. You don't make lactase? No problem. They'll try to provide it for
you in a bioactive form to help you digest that lactose. Essentially what
it does is put the lactase in your stomach to digest the lactose
so that the bacteria in your gut doesn't have to
do it and you don't have to get those side effects.
>> So let's take this scenario, Miriam is
lactate non persistent meaning that she shows signs of
lactose intolerance. After hanging out with some friends
they decide to go out for ice cream which
has lactose in it. So she wouldn't be
left out, Miriam took a lactase pill so that
she could enjoy the ice cream with her friends,
without all the side effects of lactose intolerance. So
I want you to tell me, which of the following statements
apply to Miriam? Make sure to check all statements that apply.